ladies and gentlemen in my uh
in my short stay chicago has been very
nice to me and of course chicago's a
drinking town and earlier this week
earlier this week the goose island
brewery announced they were creating
creating a special ale in my honor i
decided to pay them a visit and learn
how you make a conan o'brien brew
this is greg hall right you are the
brewmaster here at goose island true
is brewmaster an official title do you
need a certificate
actually it's master brewers kind of the
official one what do you prefer master
brewer or
brewmaster i think um the brew masters
you gotta admit it just sounds great
yeah behold
brewmasters
we got will will is the head brewer of
our brew pub hey will hello we have ryan
disabled bodied assistant the term is
called rupees
groupies do women stand up in the window
and watch us brew
right the rupees
[Music]
oh
[Applause]
[Music]
tell me about the ingredients of conan's
beer well we're gonna use some um
and refer to it as conan's beer in the
third person when we're making conan's
beer
is that conan o'brien the top show host
yeah that guy's funny
funny guy because a conan beard should
have a big head on it
should have a big head we can do that we
can manage that i have high
sharp cheekbones what could capture that
in the beard it could be the glass we
serve it in
very nice uh i have a very thin almost
non-existent
ass uh what would you do stemware
stemware
nice i like it here's my pitch
all the world knows that i'm very pale
this is a shirtless photo of me taken
after a week in the sun
that's why i pitched to you right now
conan o'brien
would offer people who want it a conan
o'brien
pale pale i think it's a good idea
[Music]
well i think we uh
i think we should have i think we should
have an
expert test the conan o'brien ale so
here to do that once again george went
let's get him out here
thank you
i guess that means it's good we'll be
right back